is this thing on I'm live I think I
really should have put more makeup on oh
there I've got one viewer and another
this is like my own version of Wayne's
World
obviously I'm Garth not yes I'm actually
live-streaming this right now on
Facebook via its live tool of course by
the time you actually see this I won't
be live no no I'm still live for you
guys I'm not live for them anyway live
video is this month's hot new thing you
may have noticed that from all those
annoying Facebook live notifications now
watching live video from news networks
and web sites can be interesting and
that's probably what you use it the most
for but Facebook's giving all of us the
tools to be live broadcasters here's
what you need to know do not show me
your cubicle or couch but something like
this at the top of the rock that's a
different story
periscope Twitter streaming app has been
the leader in live but you're more
likely to try it on Facebook the go live
button is buried here a horse and buggy
ride isn't a bad option either but after
you hit that broadcast button you'll
want to sit and wait a little bit for
friends and family to tune in then
they'll start to comment and ask
questions it's the live comments and
questions that make this so much fun and
so different than recorded video make
sure to answer the questions from your
commenters and actually engage with that
Jeff wants to know what happens to the
poop what happens to the poop you may
have a diaper right
and the whole so when it goes into
diaper this is for journalism everybody
I don't think we have enough of this and
action one of the best things is that
you can stream private moments like this
little one to just friends and family
right now the only people that can watch
this are the people I selected in the
app say hi everybody and if your friends
aren't there live to watch the moments
they can watch it back later and when
you stream remember those video chatting
tips always look into the camera
hold the phone steady I make sure you've
got good lighting on your face
protip get a selfie stick or a selfie
helmet now some don'ts don't string
boring mundane parts of your day unless
you have a super cute dog do not show me
your lunch
not even your awesome amazing kale don't
do this and livestream behind the wheel
also don't over stream your viewers your
battery life and your wireless data bill
will thank you it's live streaming the
future
that's a good question Bob I certainly
think far more people are gonna watch
live content than create it but hey it's
worth a try at least once and if it
doesn't work for you go back to selfies
zero viewers nobody wants to watch me
live anymore I think it was the kale